first we were just told that it was
gonna just help people with coping with
serious illnesses then we were told it
was just to relieve pain then we were
told it was for legal adults and no
worse an alcohol
but now Colorado surprise wants to take
it to a whole new level
frustrated by the more moderate John
Hickenlooper is plotting weed
legalization Democrats are emboldened
they have progressive jared Polis taking
over the governor's mansion there and
they want to pass a bill to be allowing
pot delivery right to your front door
here to debate it now is representative
Jonathan singer democratic Colorado
state Rep and a sponsor of the marijuana
delivery pilot project and Luke
nephritis he's a chief of staff and
senior policy adviser for the group
smart approaches to marijuana Jonathan
why make it easier for folks to get
their hands on pot well well thanks for
having me on and you know in 2012 the
voters said that marijuana was gonna be
legal it would be constitutional and
regulated similar to alcohol and right
now what we're seeing is people going up
on Craigslist delivering their marijuana
to people's doors and not caring about
what is on the other side of the door is
it a kid is it an adult we don't know
now it's time to actually take this out
of the shadows and regulate it just like
alcohol make sure we license our drivers
get them tracked by GPS and make sure
that we're not selling to kids
well legalization has not eliminated
criminality in the marijuana trade in
Colorado you're aware of that I mean
there's lots of investigations lots of
prosecutions marijuana being grown
illegally being shipped out of state
illegally and we have that minor
inconvenience that it's still a federal
crime is it not so you want to make it
now legal to facilitate an ongoing
federal crime with the delivery of pot
to the doorstep well I think it's even
more important to stamp out a
black-market and we've got a black
stamped out with marijuana in general
though well that's because we're not
fully regulating it like we should be
well here's the thing I'm from Colorado
and you know my lived in Colorado my
whole life and you know we've seen the
black market actually thrive in the
quote unquote legalized state of
Colorado in fact Colorado is now the
number one exporter of black-market
marijuana we have international cartels
that are buying up suburban houses
turning them into grow houses and
shipping marijuana across the country
and upping
violent crime in the state so you know
there's a major impact to the black
market when you legalize it doesn't just
go away like we're told and really you
know what we're not talking about you
know black markets an issue but the real
issue is that today the owner of
Marlboro and of Philip Morris Altria
Holdings a major mega billion-dollar big
tobacco company just bought a 1.8
billion dollar stake in a marijuana
company that's about my nan oh yeah john
bainer guys when John Boehner who used
to be against legalizing weed he comes
out he's like well I've had a change of
heart I'm like I've evolved on this
issue I'm like okay how much money make
it on the board this is a big money hot
company that you're saying the board of
oh you're a consultant tough so what's
not let's disabuse ourselves of the
notion that this is all for regulating
and we want to make everything safe this
is about big money if there weren't
billions in this representative Senger I
wouldn't be talking about this is all a
money-making operation I look I'm a
capitalist but it's also you have to you
have to look at who's funding this and
why and and then maybe ask the question
is it good for especially young people
who are using this in greater numbers
today because of the overall legalized
legalization push trying it earlier and
having more developmental problems as a
result not not so much the older people
but the young developing brain it's a
disaster to start smoking pot or
ingesting pot at an early age well
that's where all three of us are gonna
agree this is not for kids unless you're
talking to a doctor this is not
something that kids should be having and
in terms of the money John Bainer
supporting this you know the bill that I
ran last year was supported by a
libertarian Republican this isn't a
democratic or republican a libertarian
Republicans if want you know think that
you know in fetta means should well and
if everything happened in a vacuum then
great you know if this stuff
if smoking a joint didn't affect people
on the roads then great but you know it
does and there are moms in fact moms
who've been on the show whose daughters
died in a car accident from a marijuana
impaired driver and that's happening
that's doubled in Colorado since leak
how would it work well they've gotten
worse how would it work on the delivery
like just play it out for me so you
would go on a on a kind of like an uber
style website for or on your app just
for pot or would it be
uber drivers could also themselves just
deliver it I'm just not even
how it would work well first of all
impaired driving is incredibly serious
I've been to the funeral of a friend of
mine who lost his stepdaughter to an
impaired driver it was paired with both
alcohol and marijuana I wasn't strong
enough our laws aren't strong enough
around that but the way that this works
it works just like uber uber eats you
you can dial something up and you've got
a licensed GPS track person who shows up
who's checking ID who's making sure that
this isn't getting anything answer kids
here's the thing though is in Colorado
we've seen youth use rise so in all the
states that legalized youth uses up 14%
in Nevada it's up 45% 12 and up so you
know laws laid with the best of
intentions have still had horrific
impacts and not only that but we're
talking about apps now we're talking
about technology we're talking about new
innovations that this big tobacco
industry is I want to I want to have you
guys back on when polis gets sworn in we
see this thing go forward in the first
six months thank you so much and